en tout cas quel que soit le prix à
payer la rentrée cette année est à
l'éffigie de ces belles sur papier glacé
qui font rêver les jeunes branchés on
s'arrache le classeur naomi campbell ou
le cahier kate moss un minimum pour être
au bout du jour nathalie georges eric
taxil reportage bienvenue dans le rayon
des écoliers plus tôt dans le monde de
la mode
car pour être in à la rentrée il faut
être au top la collection 95 du matériel
scolaire est largement inspirée par les
créateurs de prêt-à-porter et l'image
des mannequins et avoir des créatures de
rêve sur son classeur ça vous change un
homme
et ça trouve les jeunes filles passent
et les mains
oui pourquoi vous avez choisi ce cas ça
qui est bon c'est le mec mon côté j'ai
craqué aussi queen et oui un beau garçon
c'est tout de même plus motivant pour
travailler les marques de vêtements sont
également entrer sur ce marché juteux
thilo creek sky et cacharel sac blanc
bleu et agents des chipies tous les
articles de son tennis tu arraches dans
les rayons indispensable pour organiser
son emploi du temps mieux que les autres
l'épave aussi suit la tendance pourvu
que les petits soient contents est-ce
que vous avez tendance aussi à suivre la
mode ont séché association des gamins au
niveau de l'école donc sont eux j'ai 6
ans que chez union l'autre françois rime
moi là bas même chose c'est pas utile
d'acheter quelque chose que le gamin
n'utilisera pas les plus petits restent
fidèles aux valeurs sûres avec à
l'esprit l'idée d'acquérir la panoplie
complète que tu cherches une trousse
barbie fait 35 marvelien vient voir tout
va revivre ainsi pour faire comme tout
le monde il faut accepter la loi du
total look une même marque à la mode
pour les chaussures les vêtements et le
cartable est tout ce qu'il ya dedans
à condition bien sûr d'y mettre le prix